Willkommen bei MemodoAI.
In den nächsten gut 20 Minuten
gehen wir alles durch, was du brauchst,
um an deinem ersten Tag produktiv zu sein.
Die Grundlagen, die paar Funktionen, die überraschen,
und die Workflows, die sich wirklich auszahlen,
sobald du es eine Woche genutzt hast.
MemodoAI ist Memodos interner KI-Arbeitsplatz.
Wenn du ChatGPT oder Claude schon kennst,
wird dir das vertraut vorkommen.
Der Hauptunterschied: Es läuft auf Infrastruktur, die wir kontrollieren,
sodass interne Daten in Memodos Umgebung bleiben.
Du kannst es für das Naheliegende nutzen: E-Mails entwerfen, Dokumente zusammenfassen,
unbekannte Konzepte erklären, grobe Notizen aufpolieren, und für ein paar weniger naheliegende
Dinge: mit deinen eigenen Dateien chatten, kleine Agents bauen, die auf eine wiederkehrende
Aufgabe zugeschnitten sind, und interaktive Artifacts direkt im Chat darstellen.
Zwei Grundregeln, bevor wir loslegen.
MemodoAI ist großartig als schneller erster Entwurf.
Es ist keine verlässliche Wahrheitsquelle.
Prüfe immer Fakten, die wichtig sind, und wenn du mit sensiblen Daten arbeitest, gilt das
Prinzip,
nur so viel zu nutzen wie nötig, weiterhin. Wir kommen darauf zurück, wenn wir später über PII-
Warnungen sprechen.
Die Oberfläche hat drei Bereiche, von links nach rechts. Ganz links ist eine Spalte mit Icons,
dein Steuer-
pult. Von oben nach unten: Seitenleiste öffnen oder schließen, neuen Chat starten, dein Chat-
Verlauf,
der Agent Builder, Prompts, Memories, Bookmarks, Dateien anhängen, Parameter, und ganz
unten dein Konto-Avatar.
Fahre über eines, um seinen Namen zu sehen.
Rechts von diesen Icons ist die Konversations-Seitenleiste, in der deine bisherigen Chats
nach Aktualität gruppiert sind.
Und in der großen mittleren Spalte arbeitest du tatsächlich.
Die obere Leiste zeigt das aktive Modell oder den Agent.
Im Composer unten tippst du.
Der Composer hat vier Buttons, die sein Verhalten ändern.
Eine Büroklammer zum Anhängen von Dateien, ein Schieberegler-Icon zum Anpassen der Parameter,
ein Such-Button fürs Web und ein File-Search-Button, um mit Dokumenten zu chatten.
Wir gehen jeden davon der Reihe nach durch.
Senden wir unsere erste Nachricht.
Das Standardmodell ist GPT-5, und solange du keinen Grund hast, es zu ändern,
ist es für fast alles die richtige Wahl.
Ich tippe eine Frage, etwas, das du an einem Arbeitstag wirklich fragen würdest.
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen OKRs und KPIs?
Gib mir eine klare Erklärung, die ich mit meinem Team teilen kann.
Das schicke ich ab.
Beachte, dass der Chat sich automatisch betitelt, sobald das Modell fertig ist.
Es wählt etwas Beschreibendes basierend auf dem Inhalt.
Du kannst ihn jederzeit manuell umbenennen, indem du in der Seitenleiste über den Titel fährst.
Unter jeder Antwort des Assistenten siehst du eine Reihe von Icons.
Von links nach rechts: vorlesen, kopieren, bearbeiten, forken,
was bedeutet, ab diesem Punkt in einem neuen Zweig des Chats weiterzumachen.
Daumen hoch, Daumen runter und neu generieren. Ein kurzer Tipp, wenn wir schon dabei sind: Wenn dir
eine Antwort nicht gefällt,
ist es fast immer besser, deine ursprüngliche Nachricht zu bearbeiten und erneut zu senden, als
mit dem Modell zu
diskutieren. Klicke auf das Stift-Icon deiner Nachricht, verfeinere die Frage, und
du bekommst eine
sauberere Antwort in weniger Schritten. Gleicher Chat, weniger Rauschen. Klicke auf den Modellnamen
in der oberen Leiste,
um die Auswahl zu öffnen. Du siehst zwei Gruppen. Die erste ist MemodoAI. Das sind die Basis-
modelle, die verfügbar sind
in deiner Instanz. Aktuell ist das GPT-5 mit Dokument-Upload. Die zweite
ist My Agents.
Das sind vorkonfigurierte Assistenten, die du oder Kolleg:innen gebaut haben. Einen davon
aus
der Modellauswahl zu wählen, ist der schnellste Weg, einen Chat mit diesem Agent zu starten. Die Faust-
regel, welches
du nimmst: Lass es auf GPT-5, außer du machst etwas, wofür ein Agent speziell
gebaut wurde.
Es gibt zwei Dinge in MemodoAI, die ähnlich aussehen, aber unterschiedliche Probleme lösen:
Presets und Agents.
Presets sind gespeicherte Bündel von Modellparametern, etwa Temperature, Max Tokens,
Frequency Penalty.
Sie verstecken sich hinter dem Presets-Button, neben der Modellauswahl.
Die Standardwerte, mit denen MemodoAI ausgeliefert wird, wurden für sinnvolles Verhalten gewählt.
Solange du keinen konkreten Grund hast, sie anzupassen, lass sie in Ruhe.
Die Temperature ohne klare Hypothese zu ändern, macht das Modell meist schlechter, nicht
besser.
Agents hingegen sind vollständige Personas.
Sie haben einen Namen, ein Icon, einen System-Prompt, der ihr Verhalten definiert, und
optionale Tools.
Nutze einen Agent, wenn dieselbe Rolle immer wieder auftaucht.
Wir bauen gleich einen.
Kurz gesagt: Presets sind eine Funktion für fortgeschrittene Power-User.
Ignoriere sie, wenn du neu bist.
Agents sind das, was du im Alltag tatsächlich nutzen wirst.
Das gepunktete Icon oben rechts schaltet den Temporary-Chat-Modus um.
Wenn er an ist, bekommt der Composer einen lila Ring, und der Chat wird nicht in deinem
Verlauf gespeichert.
Nutze das für einmalige Fragen, die du nicht in deiner Seitenleiste haben willst.
Schnelle Definitionen, spontane Brainstormings, sensible Entwürfe.
Den Tab zu schließen, beendet ihn ebenfalls.
Alles, was du im Temporary Chat sendest, ist weg, sobald der Chat schließt.
Das Modell ist auf Daten trainiert, die schon Monate alt sind, wenn du es nutzt.
Um frische Informationen zu holen, schalte den Such-Button ein.
Das ist das Globus-Icon im Composer.
Ich stelle eine Frage, die aktuelle Daten braucht.
Das Modell zerlegt die Frage automatisch in mehrere Websuchen.
Du siehst oben in der Antwort eine Anzeige „Used N tools“.
Klicke darauf, um genau zu sehen, wonach das Modell gesucht und was es gefunden hat.
Search ist großartig für alles Zeitkritische: Preise, Nachrichten, aktuelle Versionen,
aktuelle Ereignisse.
Es tut sich schwer mit sehr spezifischen lokalen Daten, Nischen-Firmeninfos und
allem hinter einer
Paywall. Wenn eine Suche unklar zurückkommt, bietet das Modell meist an, zu verfeinern.
Leite es an:
nenne eine Quelle, grenze den Umfang ein, oder gib an, welche Art Antwort du willst. Das ist
eine der
nützlichsten Funktionen in MemodoAI.
Du hängst ein Dokument an, stellst Fragen dazu,
und das Modell antwortet mit Quellenangaben zurück zur Quelle.
Schritt eins: Schalte File Search ein.
Klicke den Schalter im Composer.
Ohne das lässt dich die Büroklammer nur Bilder hochladen.
Schritt zwei: Hänge das Dokument an.
Klicke die Büroklammer.
Jetzt hast du zwei Optionen.
Wähle „Upload Document“.
MemodoAI unterstützt die Formate, die du
aus einem modernen Office-Workflow erwartest.
PDFs, Word-Dokumente, Markdown, reinen Text, CSVs,
Tabellen, Foliensätze,
und die meisten gängigen Quellcode-Formate.
Es gibt ein Größenlimit von etwa 25 Megabyte pro Datei.
Wenn eine Datei abgelehnt wird, teile sie zuerst auf.
Schritt drei: Frag.
Ich frage: Was sind die drei Q3-Prioritäten
und wer ist für jede verantwortlich?
Zitiere das Dokument.
Beachte die Antwort.
Jede Aussage ist mit der Quelle verknüpft.
Das ist das Zitierverhalten.
Und der Aufklapper „Searched Your Files“ zeigt die tatsächlichen Abschnitte des Dokuments, die das
Modell gelesen hat.
Du kannst jede Aussage durch Anklicken überprüfen.
Zwei Dinge solltest du wissen.
Erstens: Du kannst mehrere Dokumente an einen Chat anhängen.
Das Modell durchsucht sie alle.
Zweitens: Stelle bei langen Dokumenten gezielte Fragen.
„Wer ist für Priorität zwei verantwortlich?“ ist viel besser als „Erzähl mir was über dieses Dokument.“
Je enger deine Frage, desto besser das Zitierverhalten.
Agents sind vorkonfigurierte Assistenten, die jemand für eine bestimmte Aufgabe gebaut hat.
Sie haben einen Namen, ein Icon, einen System-Prompt und optional ein paar Tools, etwa
File Search oder Web Search.
Beginnen wir damit, einen geteilten Agent zu nutzen.
Aus der Modellauswahl wähle ich den Memodo Engineering Concierge.
Der Chat-Bereich wechselt zur Startseite des Agents: Name, Icon und eine
kurze Beschreibung, wofür er da ist.
Wenn ich eine Nachricht sende, nutzt der Agent seine Tools, um eine Antwort zu finden.
Beachte die Zeile „Used N tools“ oben in der Antwort.
Gleiche Idee wie Web Search, nur mit den eigenen Tools des Agents.
Agents, die andere gebaut haben, wie dieser, sind schreibgeschützt.
Du kannst sie nutzen, aber ihre Instructions nicht bearbeiten.
Jetzt bauen wir unseren eigenen.
Ich öffne den Agent Builder. Das ist das Roboter-Icon in der linken Leiste.
Wäre ein schreibgeschützter Agent ausgewählt, sähe ich die Meldung
„You don't have access to edit this agent“.
Ich klicke oben auf „Create New Agent“.
Das leere Formular hat Felder für den Namen, eine kurze Beschreibung, die Kategorie, die
Instructions,
also den System-Prompt, das Modell und die Capabilities.
Die Instructions sind das Herzstück eines Agents.
Sei konkret.
Welchen Input er erwartet, welchen Output er erzeugen soll, welchen Ton, und was er
nicht tun darf.
Für unser Beispiel erstelle ich einen Meeting Notes Polisher.
Er nimmt grobe Stichpunkt-Notizen und erstellt saubere, strukturierte Protokolle.
Der System-Prompt sagt ihm genau, welche Abschnitte er aufnehmen soll.
Teilnehmende, wichtige Entscheidungen, Action Items, Diskussionszusammenfassung, offene Fragen.
Es weist ihn an, fehlende Felder als TBD zu markieren.
Und entscheidend: Es verbietet, Fakten zu erfinden, die nicht in der Quelle stehen.
Ich wähle GPT-5 als Modell.
Azure OpenAI als Anbieter.
Klicke „Create“.
Jetzt kann ich ihn nutzen.
Ich starte einen neuen Chat mit dem Meeting Notes Polisher und füge ein paar grobe Notizen ein.
Der Agent befolgt seine Instructions exakt.
Strukturierte Abschnitte, Verantwortliche und Fristen.
Extrahiert.
TBD, wo die Quelle nichts angab.
Keine erfundenen Fakten.
Drei Regeln, um gute Agent-Instructions zu schreiben, übrigens.
Erstens: Beschreibe Input und Output explizit.
Das Modell folgt einer Form zuverlässiger als einem Gefühl.
Zweitens: Verbiete die Fehlermodi.
„Erfinde nie Fakten, die nicht in der Quelle stehen“
ist wichtiger, als zu beschreiben, wie das Richtige aussieht.
Drittens: Lege den Ton in einem Satz fest.
Das Modell hält den Ton, wenn du es einmal sagst.
Es gibt noch eine Agent-Fähigkeit, die einen Blick wert ist: Artifacts.
Wenn du MemodoAI um etwas Visuelles bittest,
ein Diagramm, ein kleines UI-Mockup,
eine gestaltete Tabelle, ein interaktives Widget,
kann das Ergebnis als Artifact dargestellt werden,
ein eigenständiges, interaktives Panel,
das neben dem Chat erscheint statt als schlichter Codeblock.
Damit das geht, muss beim Agent Artifacts aktiviert sein.
Scrolle im Agent Builder zum Bereich Capabilities.
Du siehst zwei Schalter: „Enable Artifacts“ und „Include shadcn/ui components instructions“.
Der zweite Schalter informiert den Agent über eine beliebte Komponenten-Bibliothek, damit seine
Artifacts sauberer aussehen.
Einmal aktiviert, bitte um etwas Visuelles.
Ich bitte den Meeting Notes Polisher, die Action Items als interaktive
HTML-Checkliste darzustellen,
mit Checkboxen, Verantwortlichen-Labels und einem Fortschrittszähler oben.
Da ist es, ein Artifact im Seitenpanel, voll interaktiv.
Ich kann Punkte abhaken, der Fortschrittszähler aktualisiert sich,
und ich kann mit dem Schalter oben zwischen der gerenderten Vorschau und dem zugrunde liegenden Code
wechseln.
Artifacts eignen sich am besten für einmalige Prototypen und visuelle Antworten.
Der Zustand in einem Artifact wird nicht gespeichert.
Wenn du Punkte abhakst, gilt das nur für die aktuelle Ansicht.
MemodoAI merkt sich Kontext über Chats hinweg, damit du dich nicht ständig neu vorstellen
musst.
Dinge wie dein Name, deine Rolle, laufende Projekte, die du erwähnt hast, wiederkehrende Personen,
mit denen du arbeitest.
Das wird unauffällig gespeichert.
Klicke das Gehirn-Icon in der linken Leiste, um zu sehen, was gespeichert ist.
Jede Memory hat einen Key, einen kurzen Bezeichner, einen Value, den eigentlichen Inhalt, einen Token-
Zähler und ein Datum.
Du kannst jede über das Stift-Icon bearbeiten oder mit dem Papierkorb-Icon löschen.
Der Schalter „Use Memory“ oben im Panel steuert, ob das Modell während deiner Chats Zugriff
auf Memories hat.
Schalte ihn aus, wenn das Modell sich verhalten soll, als hätte es dich nie getroffen.
Nützlich zum Testen von Prompts.
Zwei Dinge solltest du wissen.
Memories sind nur mit deinem Konto verknüpft.
Niemand sonst kann sie sehen.
Und alles, was du nicht gespeichert haben willst, löschst du mit einem Klick.
Das Papierkorb-Icon ist schnell.
Das Prompts-Panel, das ist das Stift-Icon in der linken Leiste, ist eine persönliche Bibliothek
wiederverwendbarer Prompts, Dinge, die du immer wieder tippst.
Klicke das Plus, um einen zu erstellen.
Du gibst ihm einen Namen, optional eine Kategorie, den Prompt-Text selbst und optional einen
Slash-Befehl, der ihn auslöst.
Wenn „Send prompts on select“ oben im Panel aktiviert ist, sendet ein Klick auf einen gespeicherten
Prompt ihn sofort.
Die Faustregel: Ein Prompt ist eine einmalige Anweisung.
Ein Agent ist eine dauerhafte Persona.
Wenn du jeden Tag denselben Prompt auswählst,
ist das ein Zeichen, dass er stattdessen zu einem Agent werden sollte.
Bookmarks sind Tags, die du Chats zuweisen kannst, um sie später wiederzufinden.
Nützlich, sobald du einen langen Chat-Verlauf hast.
Öffne einen beliebigen Chat.
Klicke das Bookmark-Icon in der oberen Leiste, dann „New Bookmark“.
Gib ihm einen Titel, typischerweise eine Kategorie wie „Project X“ oder „Reference“,
und optional eine Beschreibung.
Die Checkbox „Add to Current Conversation“ versieht diesen Chat sofort mit dem
Bookmark.
Noch eine Sache, die du verstehen solltest, bevor du MemodoAI für echte Arbeit nutzt.
Die PII-Warnung.
MemodoAI scannt deine Nachrichten nach Dingen, die wie persönliche oder sensible Daten aussehen.
Kreditkartennummern, Sozialversicherungsnummern, E-Mail-Adressen, Telefonnummern,
Adressen, Finanzkennungen.
Wenn der Detektor etwas findet, siehst du oben am Bildschirm ein orangefarbenes Banner, das
darauf hinweist.
Ich zeige es mit einem eindeutig erfundenen Test-Prompt.
Achte darauf, wenn ich das sende.
Da ist das Banner.
„Deine Nachricht scheint persönliche Informationen zu enthalten.“
Es nennt die Kategorien, die markiert wurden.
Ein paar wichtige Dinge.
Erstens: Das ist ein Hinweis, kein hartes Stopp.
Die Nachricht geht trotzdem ans Modell.
Wenn dir also beim Senden auffällt, dass du etwas nicht hättest einfügen sollen,
nutze den „Stop generating“-Button im Composer, um die Antwort zu stoppen,
und lösche den Chat danach, falls nötig.
Zweitens: Der Detektor ist nicht perfekt.
Er kann Dinge markieren, die gar keine PII sind, und welche übersehen, die es sind.
Sieh ihn als Sicherheitsnetz, nicht als Kontrollpunkt.
Du bleibst dafür verantwortlich, was du sendest.
Drittens, hinter den Kulissen.
Das wird von Memodos PII-Erkennungsdienst redakt betrieben.
Compliance kann seine Empfindlichkeit anpassen.
Kurz gesagt: Wenn das Banner erscheint, halt an und lies es.
Meistens willst du die Nachricht bearbeiten und mit Platzhaltern statt echten Daten erneut
senden.
Ein paar kurze Grundsätze, bevor wir abschließen.
Sei konkret.
„Mach das professionell“ ist vage.
„Schreib diese E-Mail so um, dass sie direkt, aber warm klingt.
Drei kurze Absätze, keine Begrüßung“ ist umsetzbar.
Das Modell folgt einer Form besser als einem Gefühl.
Bearbeite, bevor du neu fragst.
Einen etwas klareren Prompt erneut zu senden, schlägt fast immer den Versuch, das Modell
über eine lange Rückfrage zu lenken.
Das Modell kann sich irren. Prüfe immer wichtige Fakten.
Das Modell ist ein sehr schneller Entwerfer, kein Orakel.
Sensible Daten: Beschränke dich auf das Nötigste.
Wenn eine Aufgabe keinen echten Namen oder keine echte Zahl braucht, schwärze sie zuerst.
Die PII-Warnung ist ein Sicherheitsnetz, kein Ersatz fürs Mitdenken.
Das war die Tour.
Probiere ein paar Dinge aus und scheue dich nicht, eigene Agents zu bauen.
Da steckt die echte Zeitersparnis.
Danke fürs Zuschauen.